I've had dark times when you think
there's only one way out of the pain I'm
suicidal no social life no intimacy
I'm house bound and my kids have to wash
and dress me but it's the pain I'm in
all the time I just want it to stop
words of desperation from women injured
by surgical mesh new research shows 1 in
20 women with mesh complications have
attempted suicide
Julie Gill Senen admits it's crossed her
mind a paramedic and mother of five
Julie had plastic mesh implanted to cure
her mild urinary incontinence it didn't
work and instead left her in chronic
pain it's a dangerous operation to take
the device out but 18 months ago Julie
took a chance that the procedure would
get her life back to normal it didn't
the damage had been done and her
condition is now worse than ever it's
the pain that wakes me up in the morning
it's so I have pain in me hips I have
pain in me groin I have pain that goes
down the front of me legs
it's like ice-cold shooting pain down
the front of me legs
my life changed so much that I got some
days I think how can i how can I have
this as my life forever
I don't want this forever but channel
measures been used for decades is a
quick fix to treat women with pelvic
problems after childbirth such as
prolapse and incontinence mesh
manufacturers insists the benefits
outweigh the risks while it can help
some women thousands have suffered
life-changing complications and there's
the concerning lack of evidence into its
safety for that reason vaginal mesh
surgery was suspended last July as part
of an ongoing government review
despite this the HealthWatch dogness has
published guidelines recommending the
use of mesh
once the pause on them is lifted it
states there are a number of procedures
recommended including mesh procedures
while there is evidence of benefit there
is limited evidence on possible long
term harms of all surgical options
dr. Sahir
el neil has been a leading surge in a
mesh removal for 15 years she gets more
than 300 emails a week from women in
distress we know in 2013 we were not
aware of the mesh situation that we are
aware of now so I was expecting some
change I would have liked the nice
guidance to have a little bit more about
this very careful stipulation of where
mesh is used
Julie has to accept a life of constant
pain not being able to work fairly walk
all for a procedure she said she didn't
need I miss helping people lives and I
miss interacting with people if I could
go back tomorrow I would go back like
thousands of women who've experienced
the life-changing downside Julie wants
the use of mesh to be suspended and
investigated Charlotte Lomas Sky News